LIE  SANDY HOOK
MASSACRE WA.
JONES CALLED THE JUDGE A TYRANT
PLEA.
JEAN?>> Reporter: IRONICALLY E
HEUSE,
>> TRAVESTY OF AMERAS,RECTLYO T.
JUSTICE, AND THIS JUDGE IS A
OUE NNECTICUT COUR
E LL SANDY HOOK SN'T
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL MASSACRE A
HOAX.
>> I WAS NOT WRONG ABOUT SANDY E
>> JGEONG WITH HIS NOT
COMPLYERY ORDERS AND
WERER DEFAMING THE
E CASE.
>> SHE'S NOW ORDERED M NOT
NOCENT AND ORDERED ME
TO
SAHOOK
THAT'S OING ME TURE
S COME DAY THAT
JURORSECHO
TO PAY THE PLAINTIFFS FOR SAYING
E SHOOTING WAS HX.
CLS
REVIEWING JONES' CBUSINESS MODE
>> I SAID THEY'RE LAUNG NG READH
THE NGRESSTE.
THEY AREOI AFTER OURGUNS, LOOK
AND THEN MAGICALLY IT HAPPENS.T
>> IT'S FEAR OVER LOSS OF
JUHE STOKES ANGE REPEATINGS SOME
CK AS INT
THE PERPETRATORS ARET TO
ATr:DING TO WATTS'
EXHE FIE
DETION IS A HUGEACTOR IN
GARNERING TRUST IN A HUG
AU>> IF YOU DEMONIZEN INDIVIDUAL
UNDER FALSE ETSE
EXAMPLE, IF YOU SAY THATHEY'RE
ACTING OR AN EVENT DIDN'T OCCUR.
YOR , THIS IUN
ETENSES BUT IT MAKAUDIENCE ANGR
RIR INM. TESTIFIED BETWEEN 201
2018, ALEX JONES' SANDY HOOK
LIES HAD A
SOCIAL MEDIA.
HOOK, THNI THA CLD50ULATIOGES AD
RT
THE FAMILYTHE S.
OM. RELIVE TH
THE INTENTD THATHESE FAMILS REA
IONAL
BECAUSOF THE MON
MADE.
ANOTHER G,N IS GOING TO DETERMIN
DAS CA